bueno la mía es la historia de una mujer
que desde niña soñó en hacer lo que
ahora hace que es básicamente contar
historias no soy la única ni tampoco una
excepción de hecho son muchísimas las
mujeres que todos los días salen a la
calle a buscar los rostros que pocos
quieren ver oa escuchar las voces que
pueden estar silenciadas el trabajo de
estas mujeres se observa en redes
sociales está en la tapa de periódicos y
de revistas se escucha en la radio y se
mira también en televisión ahí empezó mi
camino en el que muchos consideran el
mejor oficio del mundo cuando yo era
niña me sentaba a ver las noticias al
lado de mi mamá y le preguntaba cómo se
llamaba el trabajo de estas mujeres que
visitaban lugares extraños que
conversaban con personajes famosos que
de una u otra manera nos contaban cómo
era el mundo allá afuera mi mamá me
decía son periodistas y yo la repetía
insistentemente
yo quiero ser periodista 28 años después
es la edad que tengo ahora soy una
periodista hace siete años pisé por
primera vez una sala de redacción
no salí más he transitado promedios
grandes por medios chicos y en estos
espacios es ratificado la importancia
que tiene que las mujeres construyamos
historias esto resulta determinante de
hecho una mujer es la culpable de que yo
ahora puede estar aquí cuando era
pequeña conocía milagros aguirre una de
las plumas más prolíficas que tiene este
país desde mi perspectiva y cuando crecí
la milá me dio una serie de razones por
las cuales era buena idea estudiar
periodismo durante muchísimos años ella
fue la editora de cultura de diario 'el
comercio' me dijo que podría escribir de
lo que quiera que podría viajar le hice
caso y me dediqué a estudiar periodismo
una vez en la universidad me di cuenta
que la mayoría de mis profesores eran
hombres y esta fue una realidad que
después se replicó en en los medios de
comunicación es decir
el periodismo todavía es una profesión
donde existe supremacía masculina y las
cifras me dan la razón
por dar un ejemplo en la universidad
central del ecuador la segunda más
grande del país las mujeres inscritos en
la carrera de comunicación social
representan alrededor del 55 por ciento
de las estudiantes de pregrado y el 46
por ciento de posgrado sin embargo el
momento en que uno revisa las cifras del
cordic kong y el número de mujeres que
trabajan en medios de comunicación esto
resulta absolutamente distante
es decir de cerca de 17.000 trabajadores
de los medios apenas del 36% somos
mujeres
en que se traduce en estas cifras en que
todavía las mujeres tenemos que pelear
contra las limitaciones como lo son el
acoso sexual y la exclusión por
embarazos dentro de los medios de
comunicación al mismo tiempo somos muy
pocas las mujeres que estamos en puestos
de liderazgo y que tenemos la
posibilidad de definir la línea
editorial de un medio creo que una
imagen o un par de imágenes van a
ratificar lo que les estoy contando
cuando yo recién empecé oficialmente
como periodista lo hice en la aparecida
revista vanguardia y en un momento dado
entre 2012 y 2013 en la reunión de
planificación participaban siete hombres
y la desire yo era la única mujer que
estaba en esta mesa de discusión de los
temas que publicábamos semana a semana y
además yo empecé en el espacio de
tendencias hablando de cultura de cine
entrevistando a personajes de farándula
porque existe este prejuicio de que el
perfil femenino encaja mejor en estas
secciones entre comidas más light que
requieren de menos rudeza o de menos
valentía
además yo ganaba tres veces menos que el
resto de mis compañeros en el mismo
cargo y además como yo tenía la
intención de contar historias de
profundidad o periodismo de largo
aliento semanalmente también proponía
otros temas que eran aceptados que se
sumaban a mi carga de trabajo y además
cursaba cuarto semestre de universidad
en esta época de mi vida en vanguardia
uno de mis jefes me dijo que yo era la
periodista más necia del mundo
seguramente lo hizo porque no acepto uno
como respuesta y es muy difícil que me
quede con una si se hace o así se ha
hecho siempre de hecho esta inquietud
estas ganas de hacer las cosas de manera
distinta me permitieron realizar
reportajes que se convirtieron en la
tapa de uno de los medios mejor
posicionados del ecuador en su momento
de transitar sola por lugares bastante
inhóspitos pero sobre todo de hacer lo
que siempre quise hacer que era
básicamente no dejar de aprender
es indudable que en los últimos años en
las últimas décadas las mujeres hemos
cobrado un protagonismo relevante en la
construcción de la información sin
embargo este es el resultado del trabajo
de la necesidad de la persistencia de la
inconformidad perdón de otras mujeres
que data de muchísimo antes yo creo que
este tipo de espacios deben funcionar
para rescatar la memoria para escarbar
en la historia y de esa manera resulta
determinante destacar lo que fue en su
momento el trabajo de zoila ugarte de
landívar la primera mujer periodista de
este país para 1905 zoila fundó la
revista la mujer donde se publicaban
textos desarrollados por narradores
pensadores poetas mujeres que también
reflexionaban sobre el feminismo y sobre
los derechos de la mujer para 1906
zoila publicó en el diario el tipo en el
diario el tipógrafo que la mujer tiene
derecho al trabajo pues necesita vivir y
no se viven y se adquieren comodidades
sin trabajar
111 años después es un hecho las mujeres
somos parte de los medios de
comunicación pero nuevamente destacó que
somos poquísimas las que tenemos la
oportunidad de estar a la cabeza de
estos espacios
vanessa teherán ella es periodista y
además es editora de la plataforma soy
la sola donde se difunden
el trabajo de las mujeres en distintas
ramas y durante tres meses ella
monitoreo las columnas de opinión que se
publicaron en seis medios en seis
periódicos locales y el resultado
también es determinante apenas del 22
por ciento de las columnas fueron
firmadas por autores por autoras mujeres
en ese sentido para mí es determinante
lo que significó históricamente para el
periodismo oriana fallaci considerada
una de las mejores periodistas de la
historia y su actitud también ante el
periodismo y ante la manera de hacer las
cosas para ella la desobediencia hacia
los prepotentes era el único modo de
usar el milagro de haber nacido yo
utilizo esa inconformidad también en el
momento de hacer mi trabajo y ha
intentado seguir de una u otra manera
mis convicciones de modo que el
periodismo que yo hago sirva para algo
he intentado generar incomodidad e
intentado invitar a la gente que me lee
a pensar oa reflexionar entonces en
torno a distintos temas y este apostar
por seguir mis convicciones también ha
significado en muchísimos casos que no
siempre se gana
en 2015 salí de un medio de comunicación
bastante estable donde me pagaban
mensualmente mi salario algo cada vez
menos común en los medios de
ecuatorianos
y decidí apostar por la vida del
freelance porque sentía que esta era la
puerta para hablar de los temas que yo
quería lo hice sin embargo el camino fue
bastante difícil por los obstáculos
propios de este mecanismo de trabajo que
yo desconocía y además por la crisis que
parece año y atravesaba este país
paradójicamente publique en varios
medios nacionales como internacionales
sin embargo económicamente estaba
quebrada y lo único que me mantenía en
ese momento eran las ganas sino buscar
lo de una u otra manera las cosas se
alinearon para llegar un año después del
2016 como periodista a río de janeiro va
a cubrir las olimpiadas esto llegó en un
momento súper crítico como les contaba
porque me cuestionaba un montón la
manera en que se hacía periodismo en
este país en que se hace periodismo en
este país cuando decide hacerlo de
manera independiente porque lo haces
casi como sobreviviente en términos
económicos
sin embargo aposté por la posibilidad
que me abrió la agencia pública para
contar historias sobre derechos humanos
en torno a este evento deportivo
aplique agencia pública o medio de
comunicación también independiente en
brasil me aceptó y llegué hasta río de
janeiro agencia pública es un espacio
interesante porque además es un medio
que está dirigido por mujeres el año
pasado una de sus directoras una de sus
directoras natal habían natalia viana se
convirtió en la ganadora del premio
gabriel garcía márquez en la categoría
texto uno de los premios más importantes
de la región la vida me junto con ella y
con su manera de hacer las cosas en
brasil conversamos mucho sobre las
condiciones en las que ahora mismo se
hace periodismo en ecuador conversamos
sobre por qué seguir contando historias
que duelen y para mí la respuesta es
siempre la misma
como les decía hace un momento yo creo
que el periodismo tiene que servir para
dar voz a los que no tienen voz y tiene
que servir para retratar aquellos que la
sociedad en general se resiste a ver
hasta brasil llegamos seis periodistas
de medios bastante prestigiosos como lo
son la revista 'time' o the clinic en
chile- y esta oportunidad se convirtió a
su vez en una respuesta a la crisis que
yo atravesaba en ese momento se
convirtió
en una invitación creo yo a no darme a
no darme por vencida en ese sentido creo
que desde mi trabajo he intentado
desbancar de alguna manera la idea que
existe de que las mujeres podemos ser
muy frágiles o muy delicadas en el
momento de ejercer un oficio que entre
comillas históricamente demanda de
rudeza y de valentía y creo que existen
muchísimas mujeres que todos los días
nos demuestran que las periodistas
ecuatorianas son valientes y en este
momento me voy a permitir citar algunos
de los nombres que vienen a mi mente
mónica almeida mariana neira guadalupe
fierro sandro echó a janeth hinostroza
tania tinoco patricia estupiñán velen
arroyo thalía flores
mónica mendoza iván guzmán y seguramente
se me escapan muchísimos nombres más
creo que son ejemplos clarísimos de lo
alejado que está la idea de la
delicadeza o de la fragilidad en el
momento de hacer periodismo
las periodistas de ecuatorianas de hecho
lo reitero una vez más somos valientes y
creo que ahora mismo la vida me está
obligando también más que obligando me
está enseñando
valiente porque estoy a la cabeza del
primer medio que se dedica
exclusivamente a la verificación de
datos en este país en ecuador' chequea
todos los días monitoreamos las frases
pronunciadas por los políticos e
intentamos determinar quién miente
porque esto requiere ser valiente pues
porque yo creo que enfrentarse a la
mentira indigna y desde los medios de
comunicación hay que asumir una posición
al respecto y desde el periodismo
evidentemente también hay que hacerlo
además como mujeres tenemos que
demostrar permanentemente porque estamos
en capacidad de hacer el trabajo que
hacen nuestros compañeros y porque
también tenemos la capacidad de dar la
cara por un medio de definir su línea
editorial y de poder llevar a cabo el
trabajo de un equipo además
no se trata de que nos regalen estos
espacios por el simple hecho de ser
mujeres sin embargo si se trata de que
no se cierren las puertas por esa misma
razón
aunque parezca exagerado en pleno siglo
21 todavía debemos destacar
permanentemente todavía debemos repetir
permanentemente que las mujeres
ecuatorianas también hacemos periodismo
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]